So could you give me an example
of bad measurements?
>> Yeah.
I mean, again and again,
you see people look at the wrong thing,
and I think the most common thing
is when people look at users and
they don't measure the number
of users properly.
Now, that's true in a company that
should be generating a revenue
as looking at the number of users,
rather than how much revenue
those users are generating.
That happens a lot.
But, it's also true even with companies
that should just be looking at users,
when they count users wrong.
They'll say,
we had 50,000 sign ups in the last week.
Okay, a sign up is not a user.
How frequently are those users
engaging with your product?
>> So looking at patterns of retention.
>> Exactly.
I mean,
retention's everything when
you're looking at users.
If you have people that sign up on
day 1 and they never come back,
it looks terrible, and
it means you're building a bad product.
Something, again that's a mile-wide,
inch-deep kind of thing,
because no one really needs it.
If you have something where
you only have 1,000 users, but
they use it ten times a day,
now you're on to something.
It might not feel as good as having
50,000 sign-ups, but it's so
much better because it's
the base that you can grow from.